Moin, ich weiß, ich bin spät, aber zwei Stunden ist noch Zeit.
Oder vielleicht an einer halben Uhr gucken.
Nee, zwei, wahrscheinlich zwei.
Ich denke mal 23 Uhr ist Bettgetime.
Großartig machen kann ich euch aber gleich sagen.
Großartig Pfeifert-Geschichten, HRQ-Kram werden wir heute nicht machen.
Ich gucke mal ein paar Videos, schwätze ein bisschen, ich erzähle euch was.
Und zwar, wir können mal gucken.
Es gibt ein paar Technik-Sachen, die ich mir angucken will.
Weil ich kaufen will, gucken ob das was taugt.
Ja, jetzt warten wir erstmal bis Twitch gecheckt, dass der Stream online ist.
Also, ich habe das schon öfters gemerkt, dass wenn man nach 20 Uhr anfängt,
was ja eigentlich nicht sein kann, ich meine, was interessiert die 20 Uhr mitteleuropäische Sommerzeit?
Ja, aber es ist komisch, wenn man nach 20 Uhr anfängt,
dann dauert es oftmals viel länger,
bis Twitch kapiert hat, dass der Stream online ist, als vorher.
Vielleicht ist da einfach mehr los hier in der Region, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Macht aber nichts.
Dann muss man halt anstatt zwei, drei Minuten, vier, fünf Minuten warten und gut ist.
Boah, ein Chainlore.
Übrigens wisst ihr, was angekommen ist?
Jetzt Chainlore, wo ich dich gerade sehe.
Weißt du, was angekommen ist?
Der Xiaomi-Pet, das Xiaomi, wie soll man das aussprechen, Alter?
Alter, der Xiaomi-Smart-Pet-Fountain ist angekommen.
Jetzt sage ich Refuse zu.
Ja, oh, mein Auge, mein Auge ist zu hell, ist zu hell, ist auch nicht besser.
Alter, die China-Chinesen, die haben Bilder im Hintergrund.
Ja, dieses Teil, ich habe das bestellt.
Ich habe ja schon zwei.
Nee, heute flashen wir, heute flashen wir nicht.
Katzenbrunnen, aber ohne smart, smarte Functions.
Ja, also die sagen mir nicht, wann der Filter dreckig ist und wann der Wasserstand niedrig
ist und so was.
Ach, was auch immer.
Ich werde aber nicht drei Brunnen behalten, zwei reichen, also eins schmeiße ich weg.
Zumindest das Ding ist da.
Ich habe es vorhin eingeschaltet.
Das einzige, was ich gesehen habe, ist, das Ding macht einen offenen WLAN-Access-Point.
Kauf es dir zehnmal.
Das Problem ist gar nicht so sehr das Kaufen von den zehn Stück.
Sondern, dass man da regelmäßig Filter und sowas wechseln muss und da habe ich einfach
keinen Bock drauf, das bei zehn, das bei zehn Geräten zu machen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob man das Ding ordentlich ins WLAN integrieren kann, ohne, dass man
die Xiaomi-App braucht.
Ich vermute mal wieder, dass das nicht funktioniert.
J-Law, suchst du einen Job oder wie?
So.
Wer ist sonst noch da?
Ja.
Der Ogi-Frosch, moin.
Die Tabs, die Stripes, dankeschön für den Sub.
45 mehr Monate, das ist ja...
Nice, nice, nice.
Morgen früh keinen Stream stellst, doch?
Morgen früh auch.
Ich gehe quasi um 23 Uhr auf, dann penne ich, dann komme ich an und mache wieder Stream
an.
Was, du hast ein sechs Monats-Abo?
Geht das überhaupt?
Wusste gar nicht, dass man mehrere Monate gleichzeitig überhaupt abonnieren kann.
Jetzt siehst du mal.
Jetzt siehst du mal, wie viel man abonnieren kann.
Jetzt siehst du mal, wie planlos ich bin.
Jetzt siehst du mal, wie planlos ich bin, was Twitch angeht.
Ich glaube, ich habe auf Twitch, jetzt, jetzt kommt's, aber ich bin mir eigentlich relativ
sicher, dass es stimmt.
Und zwar, ich habe auf Twitch noch nie, außer mit Prime, beides...
Es könnte sein, dass ich ganz, ganz früher mal einmal beim Lost subscribt habe.
Mit normalem Money und einmal bei Krubby subscribt habe mit normalem Money.
Aber ansonsten mache ich immer nur Prime-Subscription.
Ja, heute ein bisschen später, aber zwei Stunden Zeit habe ich noch.
Ja, React sagt ja auch.
Bei React, React ist halt immer noch das Verbreitetste.
Was, dein längstes Abo ist 103 Monate?
Krasser Scheiß, Alter.
Na ja, aber...
Ja, wahrscheinlich früher.
Ja, wahrscheinlich früher bei Indie Fox und jetzt...
Und jetzt...
Ne, Moment, wie hieß die?
Und jetzt dort.
Ne, ganz ehrlich, Vue ist auch ein bisschen auf dem absteigenden Ast, habe ich den Eindruck.
Weil React ist, wenn man einen Job sucht, auf jeden Fall das Beste.
Wobei für mich ja immer noch Svelte Gigachat ist.
PubaTV.
Ja, das war mir so klar, dass es da schon wieder welche gibt, die, die dafür...
Ach du Scheiß, ich habe es gerade auf dem zweiten Bildschirm auf.
Lull, Alter.
PubaTV.
Was zum Teufel geht da ab, Mann?
Das ist doch nicht normal, Mann.
Sag mal, das sind doch alles irgendwelche Camgirls, die halt auf Twitch nebenbei noch streamen
und da halt ein bisschen mehr anhaben.
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären, wie viel es bei PubaTV gibt.
Aber ich finde es interessant, dass der Chandler wieder die Seiten parat hat.
Wann gibt es endlich Narrow People Z?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt das Emote gibt.
Aber das wäre ein gutes Gegenstück zu White People Happy.
Naja, das Gegenteil von White People Happy ist ja der normale.
Normal Size.
Da kaut eine am Mikrofon.
Ja, das machen da viele gerne.
Das wird dann als ASMR...
ASMR Mouth Sounds oder so verkauft.
Also, wenn mir einer...
Ich habe ja noch Emote Slots.
Wenn mir einer eine Narrow People Z baut, dann haue ich den rein.
Ach, gibt es tatsächlich.
Narrow People Z.
Okay, das ist aber die schlechteste Auflösung, die mir einfällt.
Guck dir das mal an.
Das kann man doch nicht als Emote nehmen.
Das ist ja Pixel hoch 10.
Was ist das?
Wo haben sie denn das?
Hat er das abfotografiert von einem alten Nokia Handy oder was?
Sowas...
Nee, das kann ich nicht reinmachen.
Ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen Quality muss schon sein bei den Emotes.
Hi, du hast in einem...
Moment nochmal.
Hi, du hast in deinem neuen Video dich über Mobile X-Tone Putty beschwert.
Was nimmt man denn unter Windows am besten?
Also, ich habe ja hier daheim, zumindest hier auch, wenn ich streame und so, den Luxus,
dass ich nicht Windows benutzen muss für...
Also, ich meine, ich habe hier meine Linux VM und zwar unter Windows,
aber ich mache die ganzen Sachen unter Linux.
Also, das ist eigentlich ein ganz nicer Workflow.
Allerdings, was würde ich unter Windows benutzen?
Wahrscheinlich mittlerweile das Gleiche.
Also, wenn ich mir aussuchen könnte.
Ja, wahrscheinlich das Gleiche, was ich auch unter Linux benutze, nämlich Western.
Du hattest eine alte LibVirt-Version.
Ah, ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das irgendwie inkompatibel ist zu älteren LibVirt-Versionen.
Gut, kann natürlich sein.
Aber das ist halt ein bisschen doof, wenn man Interop mit C-Libraries macht.
Dann...
Dann suckt das.
Ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wie man das in C-Sharp handelt,
wenn man unterschiedliche Versionen von C-Libraries haben kann.
Hm.
Weiß nicht.
Also...
Das da verwende ich...
Das da verwende ich unter Linux als Terminal.
Also hier das, was du hier siehst, ist Western.
Das würde ich auch unter Windows verwenden, wenn ich könnte.
Weil die Releases gibt es für Windows, MacOS, Linux und FreeBSD.
Kann man sich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
So.
Und weißt du, was noch viel besser ist?
Dass du die gleiche Config verwenden kannst unter Linux und unter Windows.
Also ich könnte quasi meine Config mir schnappen, rüberkopieren.
Meine Config ist nicht so viel drin.
Und dann würde das Ganze funktionieren.
Also wahrscheinlich würde ich das hier unter Windows benutzen.
So.
Wenn man was im Business-Umfeld standardmäßig vorinstallieren will,
dann ist das vielleicht nix.
Ich denke mal, die meisten Leute haben keinen Bock, ihr Terminal über Lua zu konfigurieren.
Aber ein sinnvolles Default für Windows wäre zum Beispiel,
dass sie das neue Windows-Terminal vorinstallieren.
Es gibt ja ein offizielles neues Terminal von Microsoft.
Selbst wenn man CMD aufmacht unter Windows.
Windows 11.
Kommt schon das neue Microsoft-Terminal.
Das hier.
Windows-Terminal.
Blablop.
Was auch auf GitHub ist.
Hier.
Alter.
Acht nach der...
Da siehst du mal, wie verzweifelt Windows-User waren.
Dass ein semi-gutes Terminal schon 88.000 Sterne bekommt.
Da weißt du Bescheid.
Windows.
Keckel.
So.
Ganz wichtig.
Den braucht man auch immer hier.
Essenziell, Leute.
Den.
Bei Windows läuft immer irgendein Shit im Hintergrund.
Was ist...
Was ist Chrome?
Und was ist...
Was labere ich denn nicht?
Was ist Chrome?
Was ist Camo-Service?
Was ist Aggregator-Host?
Man weiß es nicht.
Windows.
Die China-Chinesen sind bei mir auf dem Rechner.
Ja.
Aber als Default wäre das eigentlich ganz sinnvoll.
Das Standard-Windows-Terminal.
Was es für Windows 10 und Windows 11 gibt.
Also...
Das ist...
Das ist schon mal...
Ganz in Ordnung.
Ich meine, ich würde was anderes benutzen, aber das geht immer noch.
Also Putty kommt einem wirklich vor wie 1995.
Und...
Mobile X Term kommt einem vielleicht vor wie 2005.
Ja.
Mit...
Mit sehr viel...
Mit sehr viel Glück.
Dann Troubleshoote mal, weil vielleicht kann ich nämlich einfach das Default-Device...
Du kannst...
Mach...
Kannst du ein Pull-Request, aber kein Pull-Request, ein Issue oder wenn du willst sogar ein Pull-Request
machen, wenn du es rausgekriegt hast, weil vielleicht können wir einfach das Default
im XML auf was Älteres setzen.
Das...
Das gehört nicht und es funktioniert auch mit älteren Versionen.
Parallels unter einem...
Ne...
Keine Ahnung.
Nachdem ich kein...
Nachdem ich nicht regelmäßig macOS verwende, weiß ich das nicht.
Was für einen CSS-Framework nutzt du, wenn du was damit machen musst?
In letzter Zeit eigentlich zum größten Teil Tailwind, wobei Tailwind ja eigentlich kein
richtiges CSS-Framework ist, so wie Bootstrap, also mit fertigen Elementen, sondern es ist
im Endeffekt ein bisschen so ein CSS-Wrapper quasi.
Aber finde ich ganz angenehm.
Ja.
Also das Terminal...
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Ah.
Ja.
Also das Terminal verwende ich normalerweise.
Und...
Noch...
Noch mal eine Sache zum Terminal.
STBA42.
Was ich...
Was ich persönlich nice finde an Westterm...
Die Config ist Lua.
Man kann da ganz abgedrehte Sachen drin machen.
Also man kann standardmäßige Sachen drin machen.
Ja.
Also...
Curve...
geht und zwar was das hier macht ist folgendes wenn ich man sieht es ja hier also mal davon
abgesehen dass es in der schleife ist man sieht hier wenn ich denn wenn ich die rechte wenn ich
die rechte maustaste drückt dann passiert abhängig davon ob schon was selected ist was
unterschiedlich ist und zwar der guckt erst mal ist text selected wenn es ist eine selection gibt
dann kopiert er das ins clipboard und klärt die selection wenn nichts selected ist dann dann
pasted er also sprich dementsprechend kann ich sowas hier jetzt machen hier anklicken rechts
klick jetzt ist es im clipboard noch mal rechts klick und es wird eingefügt also ich kann im
endeffekt wenn ich was copy pasten will einfach so machen anklingen klick klick und es ist da
alternativ kann man natürlich auch doppel links und einmal mitte anklicken und so
geht auch aber ich finde es mit rechts rechts eigentlich ganz nice das finde ich cool dass
man so was machen kann das hat seine vorteile wenn die config komplett in lua ist massive q chat
danke schön für den sub was macht der fia champ der fia champ habe ich gerade nicht so viel bock
dran was drauf zu machen auch wenn ich mal wirklich wieder wieder ran müsste weil wir
haben im fia champ neun offene issues paar sachen sind jetzt
nicht sind jetzt nicht allzu spannend aber zum beispiel gibt es neue features nämlich habe ich
gesehen dass die hier am start sind da ist für den sub sd br 42 dass es jetzt eine neue funktion in
der fiat app gibt dass man nämlich angucken kann ob die türen auf oder zu sind und welche fenster
auf oder zu sehen oder sowas ich vermute war das
das wäre nice das würde ich gerne einbauen aber ich bin zu faul der kram funktioniert macht
eigentlich mehr oder weniger alles was ich haben will und ich habe keinen bock das zu erweitern aber
man müsste mal ein paar sachen paar sachen einmal es gibt ja noch ein paar andere coole features zum
beispiel dass man notifications bekommt wenn das auto in den gewissen bereich rein und raus
wird und so was ist schon sehr nice was man noch machen könnte man muss glaube ich den fiat champ
ein bisschen refactoren dafür dass die das mqt über aws funktioniert ordentlich glücklicherweise ist die
software halbwegs ordentlich gebaut also man blickt ansatzweise durch was ich hier gebaut
habe aber ja selbstverständlich ihr kennt mich hier gibt es nur fehlerfreie software dementsprechend
natürlich auch keine Tests und keine Dokus
und keine Kommentare.
Leon, danke schön für den Sub. Richtig
massive Pog. Hast du schon mal was
mit Go gemacht? Ja, habe ich.
Ein paar Sachen. Und wir haben
sogar schon im
im Stream letztens irgendwas
mit Go
lernen, Go, was auch immer.
Ja,
wir haben auch schon mal
Overwatch, Kerkel,
Alter. Ja, also wir
haben auch schon im Stream
was gebaut. Und auf
der letzten Arbeit habe ich sogar ein Tool gebaut.
Ich habe doch sogar hier mal
im Stream was in Go gebaut
für Prometheus
Alert Manager abgreifen.
Zahlst du eigentlich für Copilot?
Nein, ich habe kein
Copilot, aber
ich würde gerne
für GPT-4 bezahlen.
Wenn
GPT-4
vielleicht geht das mittlerweile
es endlich schafft, Image-Input
zu benutzen, äh, zu
anzubieten. Und das
funktioniert anscheinend immer noch nicht.
Ja.
Funktioniert immer noch nicht.
Was würdest du gerne machen mit GPT-4
Images?
Ich habe letztens im Stream ein Bild davon
gezeigt. Warte mal.
Warte mal, ich zeige es euch nochmal.
Ich mache mal kurz einen Screenshot.
Ich hoffe, die... Oh, fuck, die Kamera ist
broken. Was ist da los?
Äh, die Kamera geht
gerade nicht.
Keller. Okay, da muss ich mal
gucken. Keine Ahnung, warum die Kamera im Keller
kaputt ist. Irgendwie broken.
Ich habe bei mir im Keller sowas hier hängen.
Guck mal. Ähm.
Heizung, Druck,
Anzeige.
Ich habe sowas hier. Ey, das
sieht exakt...
Außer, dass meins nur bis 4 geht.
Das sieht exakt so aus.
Ich würde gerne sowas Image erkennen.
Und
die einzige Möglichkeit,
die es da aktuell gibt,
die ich, die ich, ja, so als, als
halbwegs, als, als
halbwegs vielversprechend und, und
ja, auf Dauer
funktionierend sehe, ist, irgendwas mit
OpenCV selber bauen und dann halt
irgendwie hardcoded
an, an, an Pixelfarben und Sachen
irgendwie festmachen. Das will ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich würde gerne die Easy-Mode-Route gehen
und das Ding einmal am Tag uploaden
zu ChatGPT und ChatGPT sagt mir,
was man drauf sieht. Also natürlich
sieht das Foto bei mir im Keller nicht ganz,
so scharf aus und ein bisschen
schlechter, aber vollkommen ausreichend,
dass ein Mensch, der drauf guckt, sofort
sagen kann, auf was es steht.
Und wenn man
der AI ordentlichen
Input liefert, so hier
sieht man eine,
eine analoge Anzeige
mit Werten von 1 bis
4. Jeder Zwischenschritt
ist 0,2. Auf welchem
Wert steht die Nadel oder sowas?
Dann müsste das eine ordentliche Image Recognition
AI, was ja GPT-4,
angeblich können soll,
hinbekommen. Aber
deswegen warte ich drauf,
dass das GPT-4 das endlich freischaltet.
Ich finde es ein bisschen doof, dass sie
so groß damit geworben haben
und das auch so angepriesen
haben. Guck mal hier, GPT-4 macht
jetzt Images. Dann kommt GPT-4 raus,
man kann es benutzen, man kann es abonnieren,
man kann es kaufen, aber es gibt keine Image Recognition.
Kann Mid-Journey nicht
Image to Text? Weiß ich nicht, aber
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass Mid-Journey ist das nicht.
Eher zum Generieren von Bildern?
Ach, ist das jetzt neu?
Okay, zeig mal her. Interessant.
Mid-Journey has announced a new
Describe. Ach, das ist alles über Discord.
Ich meine,
nee, das funktioniert
nicht, weil, also man
könnte es mal ausbringen. Ich glaube, das funktioniert
ein bisschen anders. Man gibt
Mid-Journey ein Bild
und es beschreibt dann, was drauf ist.
Ich müsste das schon ein bisschen
genauer spezifizieren.
So nach dem Motto, jeder Schritt ist 0,2.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da so ein Prompt
irgendwie mitgeben kann.
Oh, ah, ja, ja. Also, keine Ahnung.
Das müsste ich mal ausprobieren.
Vielleicht taugt das ja was.
Näh.
Ist das wirklich so einfach?
Ich weiß, ich kenne die alle.
Ich will das aber nicht selbst machen.
Hat das jemand schon mal gemacht von euch?
Ist das wirklich so einfach?
Also, ich würde als erstes mal
vermuten, man bräuchte
ordentliche Images
von allen möglichen
Ständen
des Manometers.
Möglichst immer gleicher Winkel und alles.
Und man müsste jedes Bild, glaube ich, beschreiben.
Hat das jemand schon gemacht?
Also, wenn das wirklich so einfach ist, wie
hau da 30 Bilder rein, das Ding lernt,
ja, dann könnte man das machen.
Ich bin aber unschlüssig, ob das wirklich so einfach
funktioniert und vor allem dann
ordentlich fehlerfrei.
Ja, ich kenne das. Ich kenne die ganzen Beispiele.
Aber eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock,
das selbst zu machen.
Das läuft mir zu 90% hier genau.
Ich kann mir zirka...
Na, 90% ist schon ganz schön hohe Fehlerquote, oder?
Also 10%, wo es nicht stimmt.
Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite
könnte man natürlich dann
das Ganze...
Ja, einfach Bilder tun es ja nicht.
Man braucht ja schon Bilder von unterschiedlichen Ständen.
Die müsste ich... Okay. Ja, das ist vielleicht
keine schlechte Idee.
So einfach ist es nicht. Man müsste das wirklich über mehrere...
Musst du denn dann bei den Bildern
beschreiben, welches
Bild was darstellt?
So nach dem Motto, das ist 1,4,
das ist 1,45
und so. So was musst du
wahrscheinlich sagen bei jedem Bild.
Und dann trainieren.
Ja.
So wirklich reagiert haben die da gar nicht drauf.
Das war von Anfang an klar. Ich hatte das sogar
in meiner Bewerbung drinstehen, dass ich
nebenberuflich tätig bin als
Web-Video-Creator
oder irgendwie sowas habe ich reingeschrieben.
Also ich wusste das von Anfang an.
So wirklich...
Ich glaube nicht, dass es jemand
groß interessiert hat.
Reim und rein. Dankeschön, der echte
Oli Pog-Subscription. Ich sehe hier auch
bis neu am Start.
Sehr schön, dass du deinen Weg
hergefunden hast.
Pog.
Tommy, ich glaube, ich werde das
echt mal probieren.
Vielleicht mache ich echt ein eigenes...
Was würdest du empfehlen?
Ich würde sagen, PyTorch
oder Tensorflow. Ich habe damit noch nie was gemacht.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung.
Müsste ich halt erstmal Bilder machen. Das müsste ich aber hinbekommen.
Ich lasse einfach von der Kamera
automatisch ein paar Bilder machen
über den Lauf von irgendwie einer Woche,
zwei Wochen.
PyTorch.
Und dann ist gut.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz den Stecker von meiner Tastatur
rausziehen, wieder reinmachen,
weil die Logitech-Software
hat nicht gecheckt, dass es
die RGB-LEDs auf blau
machen soll.
Okay, ich schreibe mir das mal auf.
Ich gucke mir das mal an. Vielleicht mache ich das.
Vielleicht mache ich das wirklich.
Warum nicht?
Vielleicht gar keine schlechte Idee.
Wer weiß. Ich meine,
wer weiß, wie lange GPT-4 noch
braucht, bis die mit ihrer Image-Recognition
rauskommen.
Schadet nicht. Das stimmt.
Das kann man ja eigentlich zu allem sagen.
Schadet nicht.
Ich denke mal nicht, dass es sonderlich viel Leistung frisst,
weil man muss es einmal am Tag laufen lassen.
Selbst wenn das,
sagen wir mal, auf einer etwas schwachbrüstigen
Kiste
10 Sekunden läuft pro Bild, was ich nicht glaube,
sondern wahrscheinlich eher deutlich schneller,
dann ist es egal, wenn man das einmal am Tag
laufen lässt.
Was hast du da ausgebuddelt, Chainlore?
Preis-Champ.org Web Archive.
Die Seite geht aber nicht. Die ist broken.
Die ist kaputt.
Oh, doch?
Ja gut, mehr geht nicht, weil
er kann ja nicht,
Api-Requests zu machen.
Ja, Preis-Champ ist down.
Aber ein schönes, ein schönes,
aber wichtig war, dass da Beta
oben dran steht.
Alle coolen Services haben Beta. Ist Fortnite
nicht auch noch Beta?
Äh.
Leute, Moment.
Meine, ah gut, gut, gut, gut.
Ich hab meine anderen
Browser-Tabs geschlossen. Was ist da los?
Jetzt hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, wir haben schon, wir haben schon, oh!
Eigenes Video von mir.
Eigenes Video von mir. Das muss ich jetzt anklicken.
Wir gucken, wir gucken das nicht.
Wir gucken, wir gucken das nicht, aber
View-Time, Leute.
View-Time, wichtigste.
Ja, Watch-Time.
Ich muss das noch schauen.
Manche Leute, ich muss euch gleich mal ein paar Sachen sagen.
Wir gucken uns gleich mal ein paar Kommentare an.
Ähm.
Das ist der Traum vieler Manager, ja.
Weil, die haben so viel,
die haben Schwierigkeiten aktuell, neue Programmierer
und generell IT-Experten zu finden.
Die würden sich natürlich freuen,
wenn sie den ganzen Tag
die Tabs machen könnten.
Mit AI.
Das seh ich aber in nächster Zeit nicht.
Was hast du für ein JS-Framework
für den Preisschamp benutzt?
War das noch Vue.js mit Vue.tify?
Kann das sein?
Wisst ihr noch, was der Preisschamp war?
Habt ihr noch irgendeine Ahnung?
War das Vue.tify damals?
Vue.js 2?
Das kriegen wir raus.
Ja, dann ist es, okay,
der Chainlaw hat's schon rausgekriegt.
Chainlaw hat's schon rausgekriegt, das war hier.
Vue.button, ja, ja, das ist Vue.tify
und unwahrscheinlich Vue.2 noch.
Ist der Open Source? Nö.
Der war nicht Open Source
und den gibt's auch nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht,
irgendwo hab ich den Source-Code bestimmt noch.
Würde gerne mal deine Einschätzung hören.
Ich habe eine abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung
als IT-Systemelektroniker.
Boah, gut.
Ähm.
Und auch durch die Ausbildung
IPv4-Grundlagen, Switch-Grundlagen,
Programmier-Grundlagen.
Ich überlege mich, auf Stellen in der IT zu bewerben,
die eher Fachinformatik gesucht werden.
Das sind vor, klar, mach doch.
Also, das ist ja noch nicht mal richtig Quereinsteiger.
Das geht schon.
Ich mein,
ein bisschen Ahnung in dem Gebiet,
was die dann suchen, musst du schon haben,
aber du kannst dir ja durchaus privat
die ein oder anderen Sachen im Vorfeld auch angucken.
Klar, selbst wenn man das Quereinsteigen
jetzt nennt, was ja nicht wirklich zutrifft,
die Ausbildung ist jetzt ja
nicht total fremd.
Aber, ähm,
selbst Quereinsteiger haben es aktuell
leichter, leichter denn je.
Ja, das macht schon Sinn.
Keck-Schock.
Das ist ein gutes Emote,
das gefällt mir.
Add to Channel, bam.
Es wurden ein paar Emotes gelöscht, deswegen kann ich das easy adden.
Ja.
Ist geaddet.
Könnt ihr ausprobieren, ob es funktioniert.
Ja, es funktioniert.
In meiner Chat-Forschung,
wartet mal, die Katze ist an der Tür.
Jetzt hast du keinen Bock reinzukommen.
Er hat sich erst mal gekratzt
und dann abgehauen.
An das Trinken erinnern.
Sehr gut, Chat. Nice.
Was heute gemacht wird, gar nichts.
White, White Paper Happy
wird gemacht.
Heute machen wir gar nichts.
Ich bin erst um 21 Uhr angekommen.
Ich hab, ich hab nix geplant für heute.
Wie gesagt, ich muss mal echt,
ach ja, Leute, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob ihr am Anfang da wart.
Aber, ich muss mal ganz genau sagen,
heute hat sich mein Smart,
mein, mein smarter Katzenbrunnen ist am Start.
Nicht Filter.
Der ist heute gekommen.
Wreckman, da suche ich die ganze Zeit ja schon jemand,
der das ordentlich machen kann.
Der mir so, der mir so sechs, sieben Wallpaper erstellen kann.
Für alle möglichen Tageszeiten.
Ja, und das Ding muss ich versuchen in mein Home Assistant zu integrieren.
Gibt Möglichkeiten.
Ich glaube aber so, wie es aussieht, muss man das Initial einmal anmelden.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
an der App
beziehungsweise
an der China-Chinesen-Cloud
und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt funktioniert,
ohne Internet das Initial anzumelden.
Ja, mal gucken.
Novendoo.
Was ist das denn? Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Schau mal in deinem
Meme-Channel, ob das in die richtige
Richtung geht.
Kann ich machen. Ich habe Discord
offen auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Hast du dich schon mal als Chat-GPT-
Architekt ausprobiert?
Ja, ich habe schon mal
versucht, so Dinger
wie du bist eine Linux-Konsole und so was.
Das habe ich schon ausprobiert.
Ja,
wird es auch geben. So viel ist sicher.
Wann genau, kann ich dir noch nicht sagen.
In nächster Zeit
aber recht wahrscheinlich.
Also meine Katze
mag das mit den Brunnen. Ich habe schon zwei.
Aber ich wollte
mal noch einen neuen ausprobieren,
der mir auch anzeigt, wenn
ich Filter wechseln muss
und sowas. Warum nicht? Man kann es ja mal
ausprobieren. Ich habe sie heute schon mal kurz
hingestellt. Die fand das ganz spannend.
Ja, sowas, das ist eine gute
Idee, Rackman. Das finde ich gut.
Ja.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Sowas
wäre nice.
Ja, das gefällt mir.
Da müsste man sich mal ein bisschen
Gedanken machen. Am besten
also, was ich
persönlich am besten finden würde, ist,
wenn es so
sechs, sieben verschiedene Wallpaper
gäbe, davon.
Achso, hier kann ich
nicht aufmachen, gell.
Wenn es so
sechs, sieben verschiedene Wallpaper geben würde,
so morgens
der Pepo noch hier mit der
Schlafmütze
auf, aber es wird schon langsam
hell und irgendwie, es liegt die Zahnbürste
rum und dann irgendwie
danach ist er beim Frühstücken, danach ist er
irgendwie beim Mittagessen.
Zwischendurch ist er irgendwie mit der Tastatur
am Arbeiten. Keine Ahnung, so
sechs, sieben Sachen, dass das einen
überdenkt. Mit Kaffeetasse morgens, genau.
Genau, sowas, sowas, ja.
Keck-Vibe.
Ey, wir haben genug
Keck-E-Modes. Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an, Leute.
Keck.
Wie viele Kecks wollen wir noch haben?
Wir haben
also, eins, zwei, drei,
vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun,
zehn, elf, zwölf,
fünfzehn, sech,
okay, fünfzehn. Fünfzehn
Keck-E-Modes.
Ich meine, das
wird, okay, Monka und Pepe-E-Modes
gibt es noch ein paar mehr, aber trotzdem.
Äh.
Und den haben wir den wichtigsten.
Keck-JavaScript. Kann man morgen
angucken. Morgen machen wir Video.
Video stellt es wieder morgen früh.
So wie immer, so wie gehabt. Morgen früh.
Neun Uhr. Oder vielleicht
auch ein paar Minuten früher. Wie gesagt,
heute steht nichts an. Ich habe mir nur gedacht,
es ist jetzt 21 Uhr.
Ich mache jetzt noch mal schnell Stream an.
Also, eins muss man sagen,
das haben wir schon.
Achso, Moment. Keck-Bald.
Ne, ne, ich meine hier, das meinte ich.
Keck-Bald.
Also, eins muss man echt mal sagen.
Der Kelly ist echt
unsterblich durch die E-Modes.
Hört einfach nicht auf.
Die Leute machen immer noch neue E-Modes.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob das überhaupt Generals noch unterstützt.
Und Generals ist so alt, da gab es noch gar keine E-Mode-App.
So spät, ja.
Aber ich habe nichts großartig vor.
Ich setze einfach da,
gucke in den Chat und labere
ein bisschen. Mehr ist heute nicht.
Morgen früh dann wieder aufwachen, streamen.
Ich mache mal kurz eine Runde.
4M-Update kann ja auch nichts schaden.
Arch, by the way.
Muss geupdatet werden.
Weil, rolling release
und, oh, Kernel-Update.
Alles klar.
Ich wurde auf der Arbeit,
das ist kein Witz übrigens, was ich im Video heute erzählt habe,
ich wurde auf der Arbeit
zu einer Arch, by the way,
beziehungsweise zu einer Arch-Linux,
zu einem Arch-Linux-Teams-Channel
hinzugefügt.
Geil, oder?
Klappt das jetzt mit dem Hour-Release?
Ja, das klappt jetzt.
Ich habe nach dem Stream noch Version 005 Release 2 gemacht.
Und da ist das Ganze gefixt.
Ich kann euch auch
nur fette Männer über 30 trainieren.
Tja, kann schon sein.
Eine typische Arch-Linux-User.
So.
Was ich gefixt habe, war das hier.
Das musste noch rein.
Das und die Version.
Also so wie ich es im Stream auch rausgefunden habe.
Jetzt funktioniert es.
Jetzt updatet er auch.
Guck, ich habe jetzt, aktuell habe ich noch
Version, ah ne, okay.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Aber jetzt funktioniert es auf jeden Fall.
So.
Das habe ich extra noch mal getestet nach dem Stream.
Easy.
Ja.
Jetzt habe ich auch nicht mal das Problem, dass es immer auf der alten Version hängen bleibt.
Nice, so.
So, machen wir mal einen Reboot.
Wie gesagt, wir machen heute Linux-technisch nichts.
Aber Update, Update tut immer gut.
Sehr based, sehe ich auch so.
Arch-Linux-Gruppe sollte eigentlich jeder haben.
Und ich verstehe gar nicht, wie die Leute was anderes als Arch-Linux verwenden können.
Versteht ihr das?
Ist mir absolut schleierhaft.
Und natürlich fast wichtiger noch, wie es zu verwenden, ist es zu erzählen, dass man es benutzt.
Deswegen mache ich das auch immer ausgiebig jeden Stream.
By the way.
Außerdem gibt es ASCII-Quarium nur unter Arch-Linux.
Was gar nicht stimmt.
Aber im Package-Manager gibt es das glaube ich wirklich nur unter Arch-Linux.
Schlimmer als die Veganer.
Ich glaube, das ist ähnlich.
Deswegen, also, du kannst ja bei Veganern, gibt es ja so diesen Witz, so nach dem Motto, woran erkennst du, dass einer Veganer ist.
Er wird es dir erzählen, also gar nicht, er erzählt es dir und das passt bei Arch-Linux-Usern genauso.
Generell ist es, eigentlich sind es nicht nur Arch-Linux-User, Linux-User neigen dazu, es gerne zu erzählen, dass sie Linux-User sind.
Allerdings Mac-User auch.
Nur Windows-User erzählen das nicht.
Gut, es ist ja auch so der Mainstream-Windows zu benutzen, das ist jetzt nichts besonderes, was man hervorheben muss.
Unter anderen Distros ist es nicht das gleiche, so sieht es aus.
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es bedeutet, aber Pogu-Subscription.
Warum ist das bei dir schneller?
Wenn du eine Taste drückst, du kannst Pfeiltasten drücken, dann ist es noch schneller, du kannst Leertasten drücken.
Also, ich kenne, du kannst Leertaste drücken, dann ist es schneller und du kannst Pfeiltaste drücken, dann ist es noch schneller.
Warum und weshalb, keine Ahnung.
Trinken, nice, ja, getrunken habe ich schon gerade, passt schon.
Subsystem von Linux wird dann erwähnt, ja, logisch, logisch.
Das ist ja schon ein bisschen, schon ein bisschen nicht so Mainstreamig.
Ja, so muss das sein.
Es macht ja auch keinen Sinn, irgendwelche anderen Sachen als außer Linux.
Linux zu virtualisieren ist doch mal total abartig.
Starte mal Hollywood habe ich nicht mehr drauf.
So, gut, nice.
Ach ja, ich wollte, ich wollte euch ja mal was fragen.
Wo ist denn mein aktuelles Video?
Hier.
Als erstes wollte ich euch mal was fragen.
Wie findet ihr den Titel des Videos?
In Kombination mit dem Thumbnail?
Reißerisch?
Ja, schon.
Schon, ja.
Könnte man so sagen.
Aber ich finde den Titel gut.
So läuft das aktuelle YouTube-Game halt.
Wusste nicht, was es ist auf dem Thumbnail.
Äh, ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist, ach, jetzt erkenne ich es.
Das ist der Kopf von einer, die vorm Notebook sitzt.
Ja, das hätte, das könnte genauso gut sein.
Das könnte so gut ein Rasierpinsel sein.
Also das, was man hier sieht auf der, das könnte auch ein Rasierpinsel sein.
Das erkennt man eigentlich gar nicht.
Ja, habe ich.
Ja.
Zumindest, zumindest was ich ein bisschen, was ich ein bisschen merkwürdig fand, ist.
Aber das Thumbnail vom, vom Auftritt der Titel ist schon, ist schon gut für aktuelles, aktuelles YouTube.
Es, es haben manche Leute Comments geschrieben.
Da, da weiß ich nicht so genau, ob die das ernst meinen.
Beziehungsweise, was, was so der Hinter, der Hintergedanke ist.
Das Game ist tatsächlich ganz lustig.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das hier auf easy gespielt.
Auf easy ist es wirklich easy.
Auf normal ist das Spiel gar nicht so einfach da durchzukommen.
So für zwischendurch ist es ganz nice.
Kostet doch, glaube ich, irgendwie nur acht Euro oder so.
Ähm, es hat, ja, es gab zum Beispiel Comments, so wie, so wie der hier zum Beispiel, so, so wie der hier zum Beispiel, ja.
Also deswegen würde mich halt mal interessieren, was so der, ist der nicht sogar manchmal im Stream?
Irgendwie habe ich den Namen schon mal irgendwie vergessen.
Ich habe es irgendwo gelesen.
Ähm, was da so der Hintergedanke ist.
Ich schreibe hier, vier Tage Woche, Remote Option, hohes Geld.
Es ist dir hoffentlich klar, wie privilegiert du beruflich unterwegs bist.
Ja, ist es.
Aber letztendlich hat es ja auch keinen Sinn, wenn man sagt, oh, ähm, es hat ja, es hat ja also einen Grund irgendwo.
Die, die suchen dann Leute, die das können.
Ich weiß, dass es genug andere, wie nennt man das, Branchen und Berufe gibt.
Die da aktuell nicht so gute Chancen haben.
Aber da kann ich ja nichts für.
Ähm, ja, ich weiß, dass ich es gut habe.
Ich, ich habe es auch anderweitig noch gut.
Ich habe mehr als genug Kohle auf dem Konto.
Ich habe ein Haus am Start.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar.
Es ist nicht so, nicht so, nicht so, dass wir das nicht wüssten.
Aber, ich meine, soll ich, soll ich deswegen nicht mehr erzählen, was ich denke, oder?
Also ich verstehe sie.
So, zumindest, also ich, ich, ich verstehe schon, was er meint.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was er meint.
Und ich, ich konnte es übrigens nicht nehmen lassen.
Ein bisschen was bescheuertes darauf zu antworten.
Aber danach meint er irgendwie, ähm, kann strategisch nicht sehr klug sein, hier gleich indirekt über den neuen Arbeitgeber zu lästern.
Und da muss ich sagen, ich lästere in dem Video.
Nirgendwo in diesem Video lästere ich wirklich.
Ich sage überhaupt, oder?
Ich meine ernsthaft, ich sage nichts Böses.
Ich sage nur.
Ich sage nur, dass ich als Linux-Admin keinen Bock auf Windows habe.
Ich meine, das kann sich, glaube ich, jeder denken, oder?
Ich meine, sonst wäre ich nicht Linux-Mensch geworden, wenn ich nicht, wenn ich Bock auf Windows hätte, ja?
Ich habe die, ich habe die sogar gelobt mit den, ja, das, das außerdem, ja.
Ich habe einfach gesagt, was ich denke.
Ich habe jetzt nicht mal irgendwie überlegt, so nach dem Motto.
Ah, jetzt hast du was Gutes gesagt.
Oder besser gesagt, jetzt hast du was Schlechtes gesagt, jetzt musst du noch was Gutes sagen.
Ich habe das einfach, ich habe das einfach so gesagt, wie, wie ich das denke.
Und da ist nichts wirklich Schlimmes dran.
Also ich sehe das nicht als, nicht als geläster an.
Und selbst wenn, also sollte das wirklich jemand negativ auffassen, wenn ich sage, also ich finde es blöd, dass man irgendwie erst für 50 Systeme freigeschaltet werden muss.
Und das nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Und dass ich als Linux-Admin kein Windows mag, ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht, was ich machen soll.
Selbst wenn das jemand sieht.
Hier die Chancen, dass das jemand sieht, sind ja sogar relativ hoch.
Ich habe es ja im Video gesagt.
Mich hat, also, dass das jemand sieht, dort, der da irgendwie, wo das Einfluss hätte, ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Aber selbst wenn, ich sage ja nichts Schlimmes.
Aber dass das jemand sieht, der auch dort arbeitet, ist relativ hoch.
Weil wie ich in dem Video gesagt habe.
Hat mich ja auch jemand angeschrieben, im Teams, auf der Arbeit.
So nach dem Motto, könnte es sein, dass du einen YouTube-Channel hast.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich gucke mal kurz, ich gucke mal kurz ins Handy.
Vielleicht hat ja einer heute was in Teams geschrieben.
Ich glaube nicht, es ist Samstag.
Nee, der ist offline.
Cake Wait.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, warum der Cake Waiten sollte.
Ich habe ja sogar explizit im Video, glaube ich, gesagt, dass ich, also was zu meinem Team und meinem Chef, dass ich es gut finde, wie die das machen.
Also, wenn er da, also wenn man, wenn man Cake Waitet auf die Aussage, man findet gut, wie die das machen.
Und die haben Ahnung und die machen, die machen das echt gut.
Oder ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich genau gesagt habe.
Wenn man darauf Cake Waitet, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ja, so nach dem Motto, Chat, ihr seid richtig schlau und der beste Chat auf der Welt.
Cake Wait.
Jetzt fühle ich mich aber angegriffen.
So nach dem Motto.
Cake Wait.
Ja, jetzt wird, jetzt wird ja auch Cake Waitet.
Auf was waitet ihr denn?
Ja, ein paar andere Comments.
Dislike, weil kein Plants vs. Zombies Gameplay von dir kommt.
Wisst ihr, wann ich ein Plants vs. Zombies Gameplay machen würde?
Oh ne.
Ich würde, wenn die es endlich mal schaffen würden, Plants vs. Zombies 3 rauszubringen.
Und zwar nicht diesen Shit, den sie rausgebracht haben, der aussieht wie ein noch schlechteres Mobile Game.
Als, als der letzte Versuch.
Was it canceled?
Ach, gibt's?
Gibt's nicht.
Also die Grafik war auch mega schlecht.
Guckt mal, guckt euch das an.
Das sieht einfach schlechter aus.
Das sieht einfach schlechter aus, wie ein Game von 2009.
Oder wann kam das Originale?
Wann kam das Originale raus?
Ja, 2009.
Ich meine, die haben es geschafft, einen dritten Teil zu bauen.
Der schlechter, der schlechter aussieht und sich wahrscheinlich schlechter spielt.
Und weniger Lanes, glaube ich, auch hat.
Also, ganz ehrlich.
Keine Ahnung, was die da machen.
Plants vs. Zombies 1 war ein super Game.
Das war jetzt kein mega langes Game.
Das war aber wirklich eine richtig gute Mischung.
Es gab so ein paar Sachen, so mit dem Garten und sowas.
Und ein paar Sachen zum Anlocken.
Und der Endlos-Modus, den konnte man auch zwei-, dreimal spielen.
Dann war gut.
Äh, schwer war das nicht.
Das war, das war ein nice, rundes Game.
Was eigentlich viel besser war, als man ihm erst angesehen hat.
So.
Den zweiten Teil habe ich dann dank Microtransactions und Karten-Unlocks und Pflanzen-Unlocks über den Shop gar nicht gespielt.
Äh, ich brauch-, ich brauch nicht auf der Xbox zu spielen.
Ich hab das mittlerweile auch schon eine ganze Weile auf PC.
Der einzige Gehenpunkt war mein YouTube-Kanal und Udemy-Kurs.
Und mein YouTube-Kanal und Udemy-Kurs.
Ja, Moment.
Du musst doch aber irgendwas
fachspezifisches machen, dass du die Prüfung
machen darfst, oder?
Man darf doch die Prüfung erst machen,
nachdem man, keine Ahnung, 5 Jahre irgendwie
in der Branche arbeitet. Ich kenne die Regelung
nicht genau. Vielleicht kannst du uns ja mal
erhellen, wie das funktioniert.
Es gibt kein ordentliches Tower-Defense-Game
mehr.
Ich könnte das jetzt weder
bestreiten,
noch sagen, das ist so.
Ich habe auch lange nicht mehr
geguckt. Ich meine,
was immer geht, ist genau.
Es ist Bloons 6
und sowas. Gut, aber
da ist halt auch Microtransaction-Sachen
angesagt.
War Quereinsteiger 4,5 Jahre
als IT-Assistent beschäftigt?
Man muss die 1,5-fache
Zeit der Ausbildungsdauer als Berufserfahrung
nachweisen. Aha.
Siehste mal, wusste ich gar nicht.
Interessant.
Es ist gut zu wissen.
Ich finde auch cool, dass das geht. Und wie hast du das gemacht?
Du hast wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend
dir
ein paar Monate lang, oder ein paar Wochen
reicht ja, ein paar Wochen lang
alte IHK-Prüfungen angeguckt, oder?
Ach ja, und wie hast du das
mit dem Projekt gemacht? Als jemand, der
quasi keine Ausbildung in irgendeinem Betrieb
macht, hast du das Projekt quasi bei deinem
Arbeitgeber gemacht,
so für, ja, was man
da halt sonst wo macht und so macht und hast
das dann verkauft,
als Abschlussprojekt, oder wie?
Und was mich jetzt noch interessieren
würde, ist, aus welchem
Grund hast du es gemacht? Also
versprichst du dir da in Zukunft noch
bessere Chancen mit, oder so?
Weil wenn du 4,5 Jahre Berufserfahrung
hast, ich mein, ist jetzt nicht
so, als würde wahrscheinlich die Ausbildung
groß jucken.
Ich spiel das auch ab und zu mal.
Aber ich bin zu
planlos dafür.
Wo ich ja nicht durchgestiegen hab, ist,
wie genau
ob das später noch
Pay-to-Win wird.
Weil die finanzieren sich ja auch über den Job,
nicht über den Job, über den Shop.
Zehnmal produktiver
mit diesen fünf KI-Tools.
Oh ne, das sind wieder die gleichen KI-Tools,
die wir schon hundertmal gesehen haben auf YouTube.
Der neue Top-Laner. Oh ja,
weil mich LOL auch so wahnsinnig
interessiert. Das gucken wir
morgen früh. Das gucke ich
immer gerne, was die Leute
an Home-Automation-Sachen gebastelt haben.
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Channel serving sizzling
tech insights with a side of sass.
Das ist, das ist doch Cheap-Bait-Video,
oder?
It's where web development, AI,
machine learning. Ja, der macht,
der macht's aber gut nach.
Ich hab mich bei der IHK einfach mit einem Formular
von den Prüfungen an meiner Sprachfrau bei meinem Arbeitgeber
vorgehalten, hatten wir die letzten fünfzehn oder so
sowas zugeschickt, ja. Die bin
ich alle einmal durch, das war's gemacht. Habe ich
das zum einen wegen Geld, zum anderen,
falls es mal zu dem Punkt kommt, dass ich das
so nennen will, kann ich zumindest einfach... Ja?
Gute Idee.
Und
wie war so die Abschlussnote?
Wie gesagt, ich
bin ja der Meinung, die Abschlussprüfung, also
die Note der Abschlussprüfung hat eigentlich
gar nichts zu sagen.
Also auf Grundlage dessen
würde ich persönlich niemand
einstellen oder ablehnen.
Vielleicht was für morgen.
Battlefield 2042.
Ich
habe mir
Minecraft 2 gekauft, Skyrim
2 und Fifa 42
und all diese Spiele sind
scheiße. Hinter jedem fünf Blöcken beim neuen
Minecraft-Teil ist eine Paywall
und all das wegen EA Sports.
Ja, kann man morgen gucken.
Er macht immer ganz nice Videos.
Homeserver-Enjoyer.
Alles klar.
Jetzt habe ich ein Video von mir geguckt und
jetzt denkt das Ding,
du musst mehr Videos von Max
gucken. Das einzige Problem
ist, ich bin
der Max. Und ich
kenne meine Videos schon.
Aber das kann ja YouTube hier nicht
angemeldet im Browser
nicht wissen. Ich meine, könnte es schon,
weil ich die gleiche Absender-IP habe, aber
gut, YouTube-Logik. Muss man ja
nicht verstehen.
War damit AI die Voice geklont? Weiß nicht.
Könnte durchaus sein. Ansonsten hat das gut nachgesprochen.
Also du hast 9
80 Punkte. Okay, nice.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr. Also ich hatte
95 Prozent
in der mündlichen
Prüfung.
In der schriftlichen weiß ich's
gar nicht mehr. Ich glaube, die war gar nicht so
gut. Es ist aber auch total
random. IHK-Abschlussprüfung.
IHK-Abschlussprüfung.
Den Kram kannst du echt voll vergessen.
Haller Rotz.
Du hast die Hälfte deiner Videos
sowieso schon wieder vergessen.
Das würde ich so nicht unterschreiben.
Es gibt bestimmt
ein paar Videos, da erinnere ich mich
jetzt nicht direkt dran. Aber sobald ich
das abspiele,
es kommt
wirklich selten vor,
dass ich Videos von mir sehe und denke,
huch, wann hast du denn das gemacht?
Also eigentlich kann
ich mich noch mehr oder weniger an jedes
einzelne Video
zumindest so
bruchstückhaft erinnern.
Ich könnte euch die nicht alle aufsagen aus dem Kopf,
aber wenn ich sie sehe, dann schon.
Können ja mal.
Kann man eigentlich mittlerweile auf Youtube
immer noch
Warum kann man eigentlich Videos
nicht mehr rückwärts sortieren?
Nach Älteste?
Das geht nämlich nicht mehr. Guck mal.
Wenn ich jetzt zurück will. Gut, bei mir ist es
kein großartiger Akt.
Ich habe jetzt nicht so 30
Milliarden Videos.
Ah, hier. Sehen wir mal beim ersten Video
am Start. Oh, mein Browser
kackt ab. Oh, ne.
Hör mal auf. Haha. Noch
das kenne ich noch. Klar kann ich mich da noch dran erinnern.
Also da
dran kann ich mich erinnern.
Da dran, da dran. Ich kann mich halt
alle Videos mehr oder weniger
weniger. Also über das
Medal of Honor Video kann ich mich auch noch erinnern.
Das erkenne ich auch. Das ist da,
wo ich irgendwie alles auf Deutsch gesagt habe.
Hier habe ich auf
Black Ops gewartet. Erstes Game.
Ja, da erinnere ich mich schon
auch dran. Damals
habe ich noch gar keine Thumbnails gemacht.
Und was witzig ist.
Ne, in dem Fall.
Die Videos hatten damals teilweise
übertrieben viele Kommentare.
Und
ich wurde dann manchmal in den Videos
das weiß ich noch.
Ja, okay. Geht so. Und
ich wurde damals in den Videos teilweise
geflamed von
den typischen
Ich meine, die Leute haben sich ja damals übelst
reingesteigert, ja. Von den
typischen damals zwölfjährigen
Call of Duty Kindern. So nach dem
Motto. Ah lol Max, du bist
zu schlecht. Du hast nicht mal Aufsatz
XY drauf.
Ich mach das hier
irgendwie in 10 Sekunden.
Easy Chopper Gunner und sowas.
Und
wisst ihr was das geile da
dran ist? Die zwölfjährigen
Call of Duty Kinder, die mich damals
unter den Videos mit so blödem Zeug
geflamed haben. Die sind heute 24
und vielleicht sogar jetzt gerade hier im
Stream. Zumindest
könnte das sein, ja.
Und manche haben sogar schon eigene Kinder.
Ja, könnte schon sein.
Die flamen mich jetzt noch.
Ja, also ich, also
Leute, ich muss sagen
es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Flames
von damals und Flames von heute.
Flames damals
waren halt irgendwelche
sich viel zu ernst nehmenden
zwölf, dreizehnjährigen
Call of Duty Kinder, die rum
geflamed haben. Und heute
sind die Leute auf
YouTube einfach dumm.
Man kann nicht sagen, dass das
irgendwelche, wie damals zwölf, dreizehnjährige
Kinder sind, die halt rum flamen und
sich halt, um sich selbst geil
zu finden oder sowas und um
zu zeigen, was für geile
Call of Duty Spieler sie sind. Nein,
heute sind die Flames meistens einfach, weil die
Leute abgrundtief dumm sind auf YouTube.
Also sprich, dass
die Anzahl der dummen
Leute hat auf YouTube wirklich
prozentual zugenommen
im Vergleich zu früher.
Das liegt auch daran, weil das jetzt total
Mainstream ist mittlerweile.
Damals war das ja noch ein bisschen Nische und
damals hat auch nicht jeder,
wenn er im Internet war, schon YouTube
geguckt und sowas.
Und gerade die richtig
dummen von damals sind gar nicht auf die
Idee gekommen, auf YouTube zu gehen.
Und heute ist es halt Mainstream.
Es gab genauso viel dumme Leute
damals. Sie sind bloß einfach nicht auf YouTube gegangen
damals. Heute schon.
Es gibt so viel
dumme Leute mittlerweile auf YouTube.
Wenn ich mir da teilweise
Comments durchlese,
da fällst du echt vom Glauben
ab und denkst mir, wie dumm kann man sein, dass man
das nicht verstanden hat.
Früher waren mehr dumme...
Die Leute haben mehr dummes Zeug vielleicht
geschrieben. Aber so Comments,
wo einem richtig entgegenspringt,
der ist einfach geistig nicht in der Lage,
das zu erfassen, was man
sagt, sind heute mehr.
Das stimmt schon. Das waren dumme Kommentare,
aber nicht, weil die Leute dumm waren,
sondern weil es halt dumme Diskussionen waren.
Also der IQ
in meinem Chat ist gestiegen,
genauso wie der IQ auf YouTube gesunken ist.
Ja, ist klar.
Das sind diese geilen Videos.
Das High Performer Mindset
braucht man einfach.
Einfach das High Performer
Mindset.
Und dann geht das von alleine.
Hast du mit 30 noch keinen Millionär?
Cringe. Ja, ich weiß.
Schon ziemlich fell, mit 30
noch kein Millionär zu sein.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass man so ein Video schon machen
kann. Ich gehe davon aus, dass
viele Millionäre, also Leute,
die das nicht geerbt haben,
beziehungsweise
die das quasi
selbst erarbeitet
haben, erwirtschaftet haben.
Ich glaube schon, dass viele dieser Leute
ähnliche Charakterzüge haben.
Zum Beispiel, dass es welche sind,
die tatsächlich 24-7
arbeiten.
Oder damit kein Problem haben, 24-7
zu arbeiten. Und sowas in der Richtung.
Dass es sehr ehrgeizige
Leute sind, mit sehr viel
Einsatz, mit sehr viel Arbeitszeit
am Tag auch und sowas. Klar,
ich glaube schon, dass man bei vielen
da gewisse
Charaktereigenschaften oder gewisse
Verhaltensweisen erkennen kann.
Und das ist sicherlich auch förderlich, wenn man das so macht.
Was man aber nicht vergessen
darf, ist, dass es auch sehr
viele gibt, die sich kaputt schaffen
und nicht
Millionär werden.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob man dafür gemacht ist und ob man das
tatsächlich dann auch
durchziehen will. Und selbst wenn man das durchzieht,
ist es nicht gesagt, dass es
was wird. Wobei ich ja denke,
die meisten haben das nicht gemacht mit dem Hintergedanken,
ich möchte jetzt Millionär werden.
Die haben halt den krassen,
die haben halt den krassen
Karriere-Crime-Mindset irgendwie.
Aber nicht Karriere-Crime, so diesen
Unternehmer-Mindset
könnte man vielleicht sagen, ja.
Und nicht so dieses, was immer gelabert wird
in irgendwelchen Telekamm-Gruppen und so.
Hier kriegt man es gezeigt.
Aber zumindest bei ganz vielen klappt das auch nicht.
Es ist halt die Frage, will man das wirklich
echt
machen und
15, 20 Jahre
durchcrimen?
Oder will man eher
ein bisschen sein Leben chillen und was vom Leben
haben?
Das ist halt Einstellungssache.
Was ist das höchste, was jemand mal
dachte, dass du mit YouTube verdienst?
Weiß ich nicht, die Leute sagen ja meistens
keine Zahlen.
Also die Kommentare, was ich auch schon
öfters gehört habe, ist so nach dem
Motto, LOL, hat ein
Channel mit 300.000 Subs
und geht noch arbeiten.
Weiß ich nicht, was die Leute sich vorstellen,
rein von Abonnentenanzahl und
selbst rein von YouTube Views
wirst du nicht reich.
Also wenn du von YouTube Views
alleine reich werden willst,
dann musst du schon richtig, richtig
viele Views haben.
Und da ist es mit 1, 2 Millionen
Views im Monat noch nicht mal getan.
Da reden wir wahrscheinlich
von,
also nur mit Views, ja.
Nur mit Views
und AdSense meine ich jetzt.
Reich werden, das ist mehrere
Millionen aufwärts. Natürlich,
macht es keiner.
Realistisch betrachtet geht es
auch schon mit weniger.
Wenn du nämlich ordentliche Sponsorings machst
und ordentlich
Sellout betreibst, dann funktioniert das auch
mit weniger. Aber so dieses
nur mit YouTube, das ist
tatsächlich mehr als man denkt.
Ja,
mit Sicherheit.
Korrekt, das ist das, was genau,
das ist das, was ich sagen wollte.
Und bei mir ist die intrinsische Motivation
zum Karriere-Crime nicht
verstanden.
Das stimmt auch wieder.
Wie gesagt, ich denke schon, dass man
gewisse Charakterzüge vielleicht
finden kann.
Bei so selbst erarbeiteten Millionären.
Das gibt da bestimmt ein paar Eigenschaften,
die die zum größten Teil
alle haben.
Aber meine Garantie dafür ist es natürlich
nicht.
Wie gesagt, aber nicht mit YouTube alleine.
Und 300.000 Abos alleine kauft ihr eh schon
mal gar nichts.
Eigentlich weiß niemand, was er mit YouTube verdient.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, dass die Kinders weiter spenden oder so.
Ich kann euch sagen, was ich mit YouTube verdiene.
Es ist die letzten Monate nicht viel gewesen,
weil ich keine Sponsorings oder sonst was gemacht habe.
Also ich verdiene ungefähr so,
lass mich mal kurz ins Creator Dashboard gucken.
Okay.
Ich habe gerade relativ wenig Subs.
Ich habe bestimmt 100 weniger aktuell
als sonst im Durchschnitt.
Aber das ist,
das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe aktuell bestimmt 100 weniger als so
ähm, so Ende des Jahres.
Am Ende des Jahres hat man immer, immer mehr.
Also ich würde sagen, ich mache
so 600, 700 Euro
vielleicht mit YouTube, äh nicht mit YouTube,
mit ähm,
Moment, nee, stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Ich bekomme ja nur,
wie viel bekomme ich noch?
2 Euro pro Sub, pro Sub.
Ja nee, da mache ich vielleicht 500.
Da mache ich vielleicht 500 Euro
mit Twitch.
Und YouTube,
nee, YouTube ist ohne
Sponsorings und Co-operations
eigentlich nicht der Rede wert.
Gerade mit meinen Views.
Ich habe jetzt letzter Zeit alle 14 Tage
mal ein Video gemacht.
Die meisten Videos gehen auch
ganz okay.
Man kann sich da wirklich nicht beschweren.
Man darf nicht vergessen.
Ich mache das seit über 12 Jahren mittlerweile.
Und ich glaube, das können nicht viele sagen,
dass sie nach 12 Jahren noch am Start sind
und immer noch
es schwankt halt.
Es gibt mal Videos wie das hier,
das gucken kaum welche.
Und dann hast du mal wieder Videos,
die teilweise eine 80k und sowas haben.
Aber das ist schon nicht schlecht.
Die Videos haben heute, also pro Video,
haben die mehr Views als damals
die Call of Duty Videos.
Das ist ja der Witz da dran.
Aber gut, YouTube ist auch deutlich Mainstreamiger geworden.
Und damals habe ich auch Videos rausgeknüppelt,
wie sonst was jeden Tag, jeden zweiten Tag.
Ein bisschen weniger.
Auch dadurch, dass ich so wenig mache,
nicht der Rede wert.
Also lass es mal aktuell vielleicht
800 Euro
sein im Monat.
Was aber echt nicht schlecht ist für den
Einsatz.
Ich habe keinen Streamingplan.
Ich mache kaum Sellouts.
Ich mache alle 14 Tage
mal ein Video. Dafür ist es nebenbei
schon echt in Ordnung.
So richtig lohnen tut sich das Ganze nur mit
Sponsorings.
Mit irgendwelchen Produktplacements
und sowas.
Wie hieß dieses
billige,
wie hieß dieses komische
Game nochmal, was ich beworben habe
mit dieses komische Mobile Game.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das drinnen war.
Nicht Coin Master, irgendwas anderes.
Sowas gibt immer ganz gut Kohle.
Also
lass es mal irgendwie 800 Euro oder so
im Monat sein aktuell, wenn ich jetzt nicht
gerade irgendwas vergesse noch.
Ich glaube, ich vergesse nichts.
Das passt schon.
Und selbst das ist ja nicht so viel.
Also davon wirst du auf jeden Fall
nicht reich.
Dann bleiben dir noch
4000 Euro nach Steuern übrig.
Das ist zwar
ein sehr gutes Monatsgehalt.
4000 Euro nach Steuern.
Aber reich wirst du davon auch nicht.
Und außerdem
bekommst du
diese Views
also du bekommst nicht auf jeden View Geld.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht,
wie viel Geld rechnet wird.
Dann würde es auch reichen
von YouTube only zu leben.
Locker.
Du gehörst doch bestimmt zu den Top
10% der Gehälter in Deutschland.
Also wenn man es auf
5 Tage hochrechnet,
sind es glaube ich sogar Top 5%.
Und vor allem, wenn du noch YouTube
und Twitch mit einrechnest,
wahrscheinlich.
Aber ich glaube, da liegst du falsch.
Ich hatte nie die Motivation
irgendwie
Ich mache das jetzt
alles nur damit ich Geld verdienen kann.
Meine Motivation war,
dass mich die Technik interessiert.
Nicht, dass ich mit der Technik Geld verdienen kann.
Und
bei YouTube war es das gleiche.
Also wenn ihr
mal meinen YouTube Channel oder auch Twitch
vergleicht mit anderen.
Ich bin faul as fuck, Leute.
Die Modkes können es bestätigen.
Wenn ich sage, dass ich was mache, dann dauert es 3 Monate
bis ich was mache.
Ich bin ultra faul bei allem,
was mich nicht persönlich interessiert.
Und ich hatte garantiert
keine Motivation
Karriere zu machen, wenn man es
so sehen will.
Habe ich immer noch nicht.
Das einzige, was ich halt habe ist,
mich interessiert die Technik.
Und mich interessiert die Technik so, dass ich
24-7
das lebe im Endeffekt auch.
Ihr guckt euch meine Streams an.
Ich gucke mir immer neue Technikkram an.
Aus allen möglichen Bereichen an.
Wir haben von Kubernetes bis Microcontroller
bis Cloud
bis JavaScript Frontend-Entwicklung
Go, C-Sharp, Backend-Entwicklung.
Wir haben alles im Stream.
Also wir haben fast jedes Themengebiet im Stream
schon mal.
Wir haben jedes
Themengebiet irgendwie schon mal
ansatzweise gestriffen.
Und
das interessiert mich einfach.
Also das habe ich als
Eigenantrieb-Motivation.
Und
du wärst für nochmal C++
ich nicht.
Wobei wir haben erstaunlich viel C++ gemacht.
Für das, dass ich C++ auch kacke finde.
Also das ist
tatsächlich Motivation, die ich habe.
Und das einzige, was ich dann gemacht
habe ist,
naja,
mich versucht mit den Skills
auch ganz gut zu verkaufen.
Weil das ist ein Ding, was ich nicht einsehe.
Das habe ich beim alten Arbeitgeber auch schon
wirklich eingesehen,
dass auch in der IT
und ja, es ist Meckern auf hohem Niveau,
aber auch in der IT
ist es nicht automatisch so,
dass die dir gute Behälter
bezahlen nur
weil du
anwesend bist, so nach dem Motto.
Du musst das, was du machst,
auch schon ganz gut verkaufen.
Und du musst sie auch nerven damit,
dass es mehr Kohle gibt.
Kann nicht sein, dass hier die Leute
im Vergleich zu
Konkurrenzgehältern
Also man muss dann halt auch sagen,
hier, wie sieht's aus?
Lass mal ein bisschen was rüberwachsen.
Ja, aber das war nie
meine Motivation.
Das kann ich wirklich so mit
Sicherheit und wie soll ich sagen,
es war nie meine Motivation dahinter
jetzt irgendwelche Technik Sachen zu lernen,
weil ich dann wusste, ich krieg mehr Geld.
Und dass ich ein Haus geerbt habe,
ja, da kann ich auch nichts für.
Außer geboren worden zu sein.
Und, tja.
Und dass ich mit YouTube angefangen habe
und YouTube weitermache,
liegt auch nicht an der Kohle.
Da sieht man auch, wie gesagt, ich bin so faul.
Ich könnte, mein Channel könnte wahrscheinlich schon
ne Million Abos haben
und ich könnte massig viel Kohle damit machen,
wenn ich ein paar Sachen
besser machen würde oder
naja
ein paar Sachen mal ein bisschen
nachhaltiger machen würde, ja.
Öfters mit klarerer Linie
Content produzieren zum Beispiel
die Videos ordentlich bearbeiten lassen
immer immer
also quasi immer
genug im Vorfeld, dass das produzieren
aufnehmen, nem Cutter schicken
das machen lassen
dann auch mal ein bisschen nachforschen
aktuelle Themenlisten erstellen
was könnte man machen
bisschen analysieren
was läuft aktuell auf YouTube
Collaborations machen mit anderen Leuten
ordentliche Sponsorings an den Start bringen
aber ganz ehrlich
bin ich zu faul für.
Das ist ja
das ist der
der den sie bei Facebook bei Instagram rausgeekelt haben
gell
wir haben mal ein paar Videos geguckt
und was hat er, was hat er verdient
Wo ist das Grindr Mindset
ja, nicht vorhanden
sind IT Dienstleister eigentlich gute oder schlechte Arbeitgeber
ähm
das hängt vom IT Dienstleister ab
da gibts bestimmt solche und solche
das kann man nicht pauschal sagen
33k im Monat
mit YouTube only?
Nee, alles zusammen, oder?
Weil 33k im Monat
YouTube only, das ist schon, äh...
Da brauchst du schon einiges
an Views. Das geht eigentlich so
in der Größenordnung nicht.
Nee, wahrscheinlich alles
zusammen, oder?
Ah, ich seh's. Ich seh's auch.
Jaja, das ist
alles zusammen.
Der hat einen Vollzeitjob
und YouTube geht ganz gut.
Ja, okay, okay. Dann ist natürlich was anderes.
Komm, wir morgen gucken
das Video. So was guck ich immer ganz gerne.
Ja, mein CPM ist
sicherlich nicht gut, ja.
Die Top 10 der reichsten
Deutschen 2000.
Max Mustermann. Aha, okay.
Alles gut.
Ja, nice, nice Chainlore.
Ha, das
stimmt wohl.
Das ist wohl
wahr.
Vor allem auf aktuelles
Zeug. Am besten noch, wenn
ich irgendwas tatsächlich dazu sagen
könnte. Aber ich guck halt
aktuell YouTube, ey.
Ich guck, ich...
Ich weiß nicht. Die Sachen, die mich interessieren
ist halt nicht so dieses...
Was auf YouTube Deutschland so
abgeht.
Nach Dubai ziehen. Moment, es gibt
Herr Tutorial noch, ja?
Muss der gar... Moment, gibt es...
Macht der noch was?
Gibt es den noch?
Anscheinend, den gibt es noch.
Insi-Modus hab sogar ich
mitbekommen, ja. Gut,
ich mein, das war ja auch wirklich
in aller Munde, dass er mal kurz
den Insi-Modus aktiviert hat.
Der Typ, man.
Der Insi-Modus.
Das war was, ey.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil viele Adblocker haben.
Und es kann auch sein, dass sich meine
Videos prinzipiell nicht für so viele
Werbepartner eignen. Auch möglich.
Ich hab schon ewig
kein CS mehr geguckt.
Falls du den CS-Spieler überhaupt meinst.
Tja.
Doch, ist die Playlist fertig.
Ob es neue Comments gibt.
Was benutzt man...
Er müsste einfach nur mal die Comments
runterscrollen, da hab ich das schon ein paar Mal
beantwortet.
Aber gut.
Kann man nicht von jedem erwarten.
Sagt mir nix, klingt ein bisschen
nach...
Personalvermittler?
Ist eigentlich bekannt, ob er Konsequenzen
bekommt, da er den Insi-Modus eingeschaltet hat?
Also, ich geh nicht von aus, dass
da was passiert ist.
Ich vermute nämlich mal, dass das schlicht und ergreifend
gar nicht stimmte.
Was er da
damals in dem Video erzählt hat.
Es ging ja im Prinzip darum, woran das...
Also, in dem Video, wo er das mit dem Insi-Modus
angesprochen hat. Da hat er erzählt, ja, er
hat jetzt sein krasses Business im Ausland laufen.
Irgendwie, ich krieg's nicht mehr genau zusammen.
Hat sein krasses Business im Ausland laufen,
in Deutschland, den Insi-Modus.
Ich geh einfach mal von aus,
er hat wirklich den Insi-Modus laufen.
Allerdings hat er kein krasses Business im Ausland.
Und dementsprechend ist das auch kein Problem gewesen.
Er hat... Ich meine, ihm wird's
wahrscheinlich einfach peinlich gewesen zu sein,
Privatinsolvenz anzumähen.
Wem wäre das nicht, ja?
Ansonsten hab ich das nicht weiter
verfolgt und es interessiert mich auch überhaupt
nicht. Also, das ist mir echt
vollkommen egal, was die ganzen YouTube
Deutschland Leute so treiben.
Mir könnte echt weniger... Also, es
gibt nicht... Sagen wir's mal umgedreht.
Es gibt nicht viel, was mir mehr am Arsch
vorbeigeht, als was YouTube Deutschland
so treibt.
Das einzige, was mich interessieren würde, ist,
ob der Friseur wieder ein Video hochlädt.
Aber ansonsten,
ähm, interessiert mich nix
in YouTube Deutschland.
Steht dein Rechner unterm Tisch? Nee,
rechts neben am Tisch.
Alle beide. Steht ja der Neue und der Alte
stehen nebeneinander.
Das ist nice zu sehen,
dass du
zumindest meine Videos dann auch guckst.
Kaiser, den guck
ich tatsächlich auch gerne.
Ab und zu
mal. Wenn ich
mir wieder quasi
YouTube Deutschland
Facepalm geben will,
dann guck ich auch Kaiser.
Und nicht
Kyza.
Den guck ich auch manchmal, ja. Ich hab da
sogar irgendwann mal unter nem Video kommentiert.
In letzter Zeit.
Man, Grabenreview. Grabenspiele
gibt's nix zu reviewen. Das Game
ist nicht sonderlich
umfangreich.
Und man hat eigentlich schon alles gesehen.
Ja, den gibt's noch nicht so lange.
Aber den find ich halt, das guck ich auch gerne. Das ist lustig.
Was hast du jetzt für einen neuen Business Laptop?
Irgendwas von HP oder Dell, glaube
ich. Aber es hat auf jeden Fall
nicht 32 GB RAM.
Äh, ByteStrikes, es gibt kein WSL.
Wenn ich WSL hätte,
könnte ich ja wenigstens arbeiten.
Die haben außer Putty nix drauf.
Okay, Mobile Xterm. Mobile Xterm und Putty.
Es gibt kein WSL.
Noch nicht mal die Möglichkeit,
WSL nachzubestellen. Das gibt nicht.
Die sind da wirklich
so restriktiv, dass man eigentlich
als Linux-Admin nicht arbeiten kann.
Nee, hab ich nicht. Das gucken wir uns morgen früh an.
Easy, pfeifert.
Ja, aber davon hab ich immer noch kein Leben. Wird unter
Windows und Virtualisierung.
Neues Windows-Terminal gibt's dort auch nicht. Die haben nur
Putty oder Mobile Xterm.
Ja, also, damit könnte
ich ja noch halbwegs leben, aber nope.
Gibt es nicht.
Erlauben sie Hyper-V
wahrscheinlich nicht.
Winged, es ist, selbst wenn
Winged nicht gesperrt ist, du kannst nur Sachen
ausführen, die explizit freigegeben
sind. Du hast keine Chance.
Es ist eigentlich nicht möglich zu arbeiten
auf dem Notebook. Ganz weird,
Champ. Ja, an- und
ausmachen ist so ziemlich das einzige, was ich mit dem
PC darf. Okay, Leute,
ich glaub, ich geh jetzt ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns ja morgen früh wieder um 9.
Dann gucken wir uns ein paar Sachen
an auf YouTube und, ähm,
gucken, wie lange es dauert, bis wir
wach sind.
Schwätzen ein bisschen, gucken YouTube-Videos und
schauen uns GitHub-Trends an und so.
Das, was wir sonntags morgens immer machen.
Machen wir morgen früh so
kurz vor 9 auch.
Und ich geh jetzt pennen, Leute. Wir sehen uns
bis morgen früh. Macht's gut.
See you.